je vais vous expliquer c'est moi et ne
pas entraver survivalistes le film
québécois jusqu'au déclin a été vu par
21 millions d'abonnés selon lettres flix
nous avons appris la nouvelle de ce
succès planétaire à un de ces comédiens
principaux
réal bossé 21 millions de visionnements
sur netflix à travers le monde
réaction 21 millions et millions oui
c'est beaucoup de mon nom je veu râpé
netflix pour en dire
bon et maintenant que j'avais un bon
succès que la grosse phase du moyen d'en
faire don ce suspense à propos d'un camp
de survivalistes qui s'entredéchirent
est le premier film québécois produit
par netflix
l'entreprise a fait confiance à de
jeunes créateurs qui n'avait jamais
réalisé de long métrage pour nous c'est
en effet assez c'est assez fun de voir
cette victoire le c'est sûr qu'on sente
douce revanche jusqu'au déclin a
bénéficié d'un budget de 5 millions de
dollars et d'une rampe de lancement
exceptionnel car netflix a doublé ou
sous-titrés le film en 30 langues
aujourd'hui dans un contexte de
mondialisation j'ai l'impression que les
langues avec les sous titres avaient
poussé avec les façon de traduire je
pense que les off on devrait pas avoir
[Musique]
de maniaplanet à la nouvelle de ce
succès a eu l'effet d'un électrochoc
dans le milieu du cinéma québécois
majoritairement financés par de l'argent
public
d'un autre côté si que ce film n'a été
faite en dehors de noter qu'au système
de financement de films au québec et ce
qui est triste là dedans c'est que des
flics s'opère à chine où quasiment un
sans payer leur pensant réglementation
ou de contenu québécois
le président de k films amérique se
montre aussi critique envers netflix une
forme de privatisation du cinéma à
l'américaine c'est sa concordance
le comédien réal bossé lui est inspiré
par tout ce succès c'est plus qu'une
cloche c'est comme un carillon j'irai
non c'est ça c'est que ces deals surface
d'où on peut même du matériel qui nous
appartient et puis faire cette promotion
sinon on est entre nous tous pour ce
reportage
netflix nous a fourni des chiffres mais
l'entreprise a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue ici louis philippe ouimet
radio canada montréal